laughing Gomez
welcome to Walking Dead Season 2 episode
3 part 2 the first part was a little bit
slow but I hear it gets really [ __ ]
intense so let's keep playing it's time
to get work get to work that's a bummer
so it's Sweden it's a follow me it's
illegal to hit children but I know it's
legal in a lot of countries [ __ ]
dangerous holy [ __ ] kind of time what
the [ __ ] was that something that will
matter later baby who is this
she's one of the new people she was with
Carlos and Sarah Sarah
I wish he'd stayed gone she's had a hard
time Becka so much sass we're not
sitting on the ground like babies ouch
go on inside
Bonnie's waiting
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
Hey I guess you're starting your day
with me we're loading magazines
maybe she's nice and she was this forest
but still I don't like her okay
she she's mean that's it you got it
of course I got it I'm [ __ ]
Clementine [ __ ] I suppose I owe you an
apology
I wasn't truthful when I came across
y'all at the lodge and I was shown a
cotton as' I never would have expected
from a group of strangers but now folks
are dead and I can't help but feel I'm
to blame no you kind of are it was for
no-one to get hurt I truly believe that
was the intent let's blame Carver
Carver's the one who pulled the trigger
he's to blame yeah but I surely didn't
help matters I thought if I was the one
that found everyone I could control it
keep everyone safe
but that ain't how it went well that's
same now what you did which don't
account for much but it's all I can
offer right now you shouldn't apologize
to her in my opinion should apologize
see though was your first night in the
yard I know what I'm so comfortable but
it's safe you mean my first night in
prison it is a prison more of a
work-release didn't they do those in
prisons huh probably I don't know I
never been to prison don't tell no one
trying to keep a tough reputation
you don't know is that when Luke and
Carlos and all them left I was planning
on leaving too when Luke approached me
about it I I thought he was crazy
I mean we're safe here you got power we
got food they never mentioned you
yeah no huh not even Luke what does that
mean well I mean that's to be expected
ain't it you don't know me do you what I
gonna say boney ain't here you wouldn't
know what he was talking about I guess
that could be it
i justified not going by telling myself
it's easier to try and change something
that's broken then start all over take
the situation with the herd that's the
type of thing that rips a community
apart he keeps things in line he's got a
lot of this stuff figured out I don't
know I guess I just wanted to be
somewhere comfortable for a while herds
have come through before yeah it's
happened a few times we've always come
out on the other end all right hmm
something to think about whenever I
consider leaving we're not gonna do it
this time I mean and I even easy keeping
a group this big fed and protected I
don't envy that position figured that'd
make anyone a little stressed I'm not
defending what he did that was
I'm alive because of him that's just a
fact
he killed Walter and Alvin Lee to
protect his own people Kenny could have
killed us all but he didn't
Alvin killed George when he escaped he
might not have meant to but George died
all the same
ain't no science in all this don't make
me empathize for that Cole overreacted
he was in the heat of the moment and he
overreacted
Luke had ideas about how things should
go but they didn't line up with what
Bill was thinking they butted heads and
Rebecca started showing and that only
made things worse maybe Luke was right
about him
I wish he was around but I just hope
he's safe hey I need to come get her
yeah she's here that girl I have a name
so they want Oh almost forgot I grabbed
this for you
huh what do you think I think it might
be for skiing it's kind of ugly around
to get it to you I don't know
oh you don't like it it's not that I
thought it was kind of cute oh come on
it's not a fashion show it'll keep you
warm you better watch yourself I think
some folks might be jealous of that cool
jacket of yours that's what the ugly
jacket
Tavia what never mind I'll see you later
Clementine I didn't mean to be mean it
just seemed like she didn't like it I
just want to be like I don't know oh
they have a plan House that's pretty
cool
stay in here for a minute I'm gonna
radio down and find out what you're
doing don't touch anything
it seemed time a lot of things figure it
out but oh [ __ ] is that girl crying god
damn it I don't like her she looks like
a kitty cat though hey you want a hug
are you okay okay I know it's it's got
to be hard
my dad's never well you didn't have a
choice come on stopping he never hit me
he didn't want to do it Sara Carver made
him he's the bad guy not your dad yeah
come on in a weird way Carver's the one
that hit you not your dad
I guess Carver hit me super hard cuz it
still hurts like crazy yeah it looked
like it thanks for trying to help I
don't know why people have to be so mean
like even when I'm really mad I still
don't want to hurt anyone yeah that's
how it is don't mess this up yeah I get
it Reggie's in charge here okay listen
to him carefully yep no problem Davey oh
he's gonna be really nice he's nice okay
we gotta do a good job guys the camp is
counting on us come on I'll show you
what to do it's super easy pick up a
pair of those shears well I guess he's
not that nice that's a shear oh that's a
shear thought you might share okay so
we're picking these berries right just
pick them put them in the basket simple
yeah while you're at it if you see any
dead branches take those shears and cut
them off and stack them neatly for
composting got it yeah
do I have to do it should use it so she
could have be okay
cuz what happened down there that was
straight [ __ ] up I don't want to
freaking out and getting me in trouble
I'll take care of her you don't have to
worry good good
cuz I'm awful at that stuff look Bill's
had it out for me ever since I helped
those guys escape so I gotta concentrate
on my work
no no t-touch night was awkward ahahaha
do that again I'm gonna go work now that
was really awkward why are you so
awkward clammy
she's an she's an adult now you don't
pet her head come on Sarah Jesus get
over yourself
does anyone here like Sarah I guess I
have to help her god dammit I don't want
to this is [ __ ] staring at it here
watch me
how do you not figure that out yourself
I get that he she needs more support how
but not actually show how to do it come
on this isn't that hard yeah Jesus is
just afraid I'll make a mistake it won't
be the end of the world if you do just
keep going oh [ __ ]
oh no yeah oh you didn't do any of your
work Clem just checking in this is such
a [ __ ] Nazi can girls are working out
Reggie yeah Bell hey what the [ __ ]
happened in here
look bill they're new and me with my arm
it's just not the easy I just I have one
shut up shut up shut the [ __ ] up
oh you better have an explanation for
this and I mean now oh no please just
sounds like you're about to give me an
excuse when I asked for an explanation
we'll get it done just give us some more
time
time's up Reggie you had a task you
didn't get it done I don't want him to
get blamed fail it was my fault I didn't
show Sarah well enough I guess it's
Sarah's [ __ ] fault we talked about
this Reggie didn't we but you just don't
get it do you good what why don't you
girls wait outside Reggie and I have oh
no no no Sarah Sarah get your [ __ ]
together
thanks for the help girls Oh sighs that
ending says over your [ __ ] proud of
yourself it's the same be packin lips
you can't even cut some [ __ ] branches
yeah you better jump off I'm gonna push
her off god damn it I want to be nice to
you Sarah I want to but you're making it
really [ __ ] hard no no no no no no
weakness incompetence what it puts us
all at risk and it won't be tolerated
you think about that the next time
you're asked to do something every time
every time there's a nice person
Bonnie's got some stuff for you to do go
because of some [ __ ] branches what
the [ __ ] what the hell are you doing
with her whatever the scene he just its
bladder Oh No hey so they want you to
run some supplies out to the guys
working at the expansion real simple
just take this over to him that jacket
looks real nice I don't know what Tavia
is talking about
yeah that's wrong clam you all right
Reggie
Reggie's dead what what are you talking
about Carver killed him he pushed him
off the route maybe maybe it was just an
excellent the [ __ ] is our problem
how's that in it it's not a pea blame
listen to me
accident this stuff out to those guys
and come straight back just be safe okay
now at the time to be calling attention
to yourself why does no one need to go
find out what happened why does no one
[ __ ] kill Carver Troy claims just
gonna take them boys some nails all
right go on
like they have access to guns hey that
ain't your concern get that stuff over
to them boys just follow them cables
[ __ ] weights talking to me oh Jesus
oh so they are right by the fence aren't
they aren't they clearing them out that
doesn't look safe at all and if a herd
comes we're fine so goddamn important
get your [ __ ] hands off you ain't
gonna force me to do this [ __ ] I
said get your hands off me or what you
gonna go tell on me I'm trying to help
you [ __ ]
yeah this is a real help why don't you
just worry about yourself stop fighting
I want to clam with this son of a [ __ ]
capes I just wanna get the work done
oh Jesus that went fast
Wow this place sure to secure its
smacking game smack smack damage Nick
that was one thing but it Nikolas oh
Jesus
hold a to escape the [ __ ] go let me go
home
go go go come let me call you Coco oh oh
oh my god
squeeze it gotta let it go let go let it
go
Clemmy close let's just take a
sledgehammer come on it's magic game
oh-ho why is no one saving Clem come on
climb I'll take this
[Music]
what the [ __ ] oh god what are we gonna
do oh this is bad really bad dammit
dammit get it did I die oh [ __ ]
that's heaven get up get out of there
come on make me save your ass
Jesus did someone get BAE oh thank god
you're okay
all right enough mushy [ __ ] you get back
inside right [ __ ] now no thanks to
you can't [ __ ] for you to do in there
now think I'm [ __ ] around now I got
to sit down here and babysit you
[ __ ] can't do a simple [ __ ] patch
job without me here cracking the whip
Jesus when I'm in the defense the
defense break oh [ __ ] who's that so much
stuff is happening I can't keep up I
don't even know yes but the hell out of
me
thank you drew blood comes away this is
this is the welcome again I was worried
we all were that's good to see you too
kid
all right listen we ain't got much time
okay I followed y'all here best I could
it haven't had a night's rest since
y'all got nabbed
well that's the first chance I got to
talk to somebody they're everywhere okay
they got guards watching everything Shh
how'd it get in then
there's harder lurkers just south of us
it's bigger than I ever seen around
these parts carver mentioned that said
he hopes it passes us it won't okay it's
gonna hit this place I know it is I
don't know when but it's coming in it's
gonna be soon oh Jesus yeah I've been
looking for places to to get you all
free but I've been able to find anything
yet when do you think the herd will be
here I don't know it's hard to say
really
but I reckon it'll wash over this place
when it does see Carver oh he dealt with
anything like this before it seems
dangerous well the whole situation is
dangerous but well we're in it now it's
what we got Jesus I just need a plan
we're so far about Superman and everyone
oh you better hide oh sorry sorry [ __ ]
okay Hank I don't like you being late
listen Clem I need you to meet me here
tomorrow about this time because I need
you to get me one of those radios okay
do you think you can do that just just
one of those walkie-talkies I just need
to be able to tell y'all what's going on
with them Gardens you know I figure out
the schedule their patrols are on it and
they're all over the place but I can
keep an eye on them for y'all from out
here we ain't gonna be able to shoot our
way out of here so we got to be careful
where do I get one yeah I think they
keep them in a stockroom
I ain't completely sure though just keep
your eyes out for the charging station
and they put most of them back on there
at night remember you meet me here
tomorrow I'll try and be here around
this time but if I Ain't just wait as
long as you can cuz I really need one of
those radios I just let everybody know
I'm all right okay oh go on get out of
here
goddamn they're so [ __ ] strict see
these guys go away for one minute the
hell were you doing happen huh it's for
me I was looking at comics there's a
whole store full of them
oh [ __ ] you best not dawdle girlie pull
something like that again you'll be
meeting the back of my hand I'm
surprised that story window what's a
word with you up in his office
so get on update now
oh that can't be good
so much [ __ ] going on man I don't even
know me
Manny Manny Manny Manny man you mean how
many times gonna say man and when I say
a lot of a minute wait a minute man Oh
Becca what she's a strong woman
surrounded by weak men ain't let my kid
get raised around that I get in here oh
[ __ ]
I gonna have to have a talk with him but
I am next episode sorry but I got that
at the end this episode here there's
like you know watching he's getting
really interesting and hit the sky come
with me I see your breasts this is me
hypnotizing you do you like it I'm
tickling your net CMR Russ love you
[Music]